BEHIND THE NET.
PENALTY CALL COMING UP ON
, SIR
YOU TALK AROUND THE GHT HERE A
THE PANUMBER
9 IN HISTORY, FORSBERG.
THE ROOM.
AND ALWAYS THAT FORMATION.
LUIS, TO GET PAST
THERE. THE SHOT,
THE POINT, HAS 1:30
REMAINING.
LUNDELL, THE ROOKIE, IS IN BY J
THING REACHING FOR IT.
FORSBERG TAKES OVER.
FORSBERG, ON HIS BACKHAND,
CENTER AND
GET TOLVANEN GOING
OFFENSIVELY.
>> Willy: HERE IS A STEAL BY Y
>> IT BACK, GOT A
PAY,S!
THAT HITS IRON ALL OVER THE
PLACE LY WAITS.
PUCK STILL ALIVE.
JOHANSEN SPINS IT BACK TO
FORSBERG!
A SHOT THAT WAS!
LUNDELL FLIPS IT JUST UNSS, AND
JUST A THE TAPE, AND IT'S
DEFLECTED ON NET, JEANNOT SAYS
EMPHASIS WAS GETTING THE SHOTS
BY THEIR FIRST LAYER OF
BLOCKE.
NOW HERE ISND OFF THE BACK.
HE'S RIGHT IN COMING WAY
OUOU WAY.
HE READS IT, AND HE JUST HITS
BOUNCED WIDE.
REBOUND AT THE POST, SLASHING
IN IS COUSINS!
IT'S LOOSE AGAIN!
EY GET  IN THERE, BLOCKS
THAT ONE.
BUT THE PANTHERS GET THIS
CHANCE RIGHT TO GO RIGHT
IN.
T.
HE'S GOING TO GET POSITION
RI